[Musique]
j'espère que vous allez bien
je ne pense pas que nous avons tout
vocation ici de devenir un jour
président de la république mais je crois
du fond de mon coeur eux le numérique
peut nous aider nous les femmes à être
plus autonomes et à changer le moins
j'ai lancé récemment son agent lit dans
mon groupe je demandais aux
entrepreneurs ce qu'ils appréciaient le
plus dans notre benaria et la majorité
ont répondu la liberté la principale de
beauvoir et seront pas le travail qu'on
peut se garantit une idée concrète c'est
grâce au numérique mais j'ai pu être
autonome créé mon entreprise
depuis mon salon avec juste mon pc et
une connexion internet
merci le numérique est une opportunité à
saisir pour les femmes avec 2,3 millions
d'emplois d'emplois alors à pouvoir
d'ici 2020
l'été jonsin fils hier la big data le
bloc chine sont les nouveaux enjeux de
notre société
ils vont épater tous les secteurs
c'est une récente ont prouvé que le
robot mais toujours satisfait donc au
sens plus à la personne qui l'a reçu
malheureusement il ya très peu de femmes
dans la tête
écoutons les débuts de l'ordinateur les
algorithmes les utilisons satie fils
hier même le wifi ou ses inventions de
l'informatique et a fortiori de
l'intelligence artificielle ne seront
pas ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
si elle n'avait pas été conçu grâce à la
couleur à votre collaboration des femmes
le plafond de verre est un mythe
l'ambition est un mot féminin
réapproprions-nous ce mot hope est une
femme ambitieuse être une bonne maman un
point leader du boys manager une bonne
collaboratrice
merci nous représentons c'est qu'on ne
consomme la population mondiale
mais nous devons être représentés
partout à ces cocons sont le numérique
représente le progrès il ne peut donc
être inscrit dans une égalité qui
dépérit disait dans la vie les solutions
n'existent pas il ya les fausses en
match il faut les criées et les
solutions suivent j'ai donc décidé de
créer une association qui donne envie
aux fans aux et investi et
d'entreprendre dans le numérique
mon ambition ma mission c'est de croiser
plus de femmes dans l'écosystème
numérique alors à toutes ses pieds dit
encore n'attendez plus lancez vous osez
échoués rapidement réessayer relevez
vous échouez mieux et continuer
d'avancer
merci nous pouvons rendre le monde
meilleur
et si ce monde et un mono féminin
j'aimerais conclure un essai citation
d'albert touiza le suesser n'est pas la
clé du bonheur c'est le bolloc'h qui est
la clé du succès si vous aimez ce que
vous faites pour réussir et alors nous
sommes actuellement dans le temps de
l'action maintenant c'est à vous de
jouer
merci
[Applaudissements]